évident c'est un document du square est
tout à fait raison de dire que
inconcevable qu'ils ne soient pas mis à
la disposition c'est le vent d'un
faciste le fasciste ça existe ça a même
failli renier sa a dominé pendant un
temps une grande partie de l'europe
c'est très important de savoir ce que
sont les fascistes ce que pensent les
plagistes donc qu'il fasse par
définition de l'antisémitisme du racisme
je dirais qu'on s'y attend et l'idée que
une forme quelconque de censure puisse
s'exercer à l'encontre d'un ouvrage de
ce type là pour qu'on en parle et
aberrant c'est donc pour vous ne pourrez
pas y avoir de loi qui pourrait
interdire cette fois un ouvrage de qui
comme celui là se situe aux environs
sûrement pas moi je vais je vais plus
loin c'est seulement si vous voyez
publier un ouvrage de provocation à la
haine raciste immédiat proclamant qu'il
faut si vous voulez à l'instant tuer
tous les nord africains qu'on
rencontrera recoller à nouveau les juifs
dans les chambres à gaz qu'à cet instant
là vous pouvez vous interrogez mais sur
ce qui s'est passé ça ne se discute même
pas je dois dire que mine en ce qui
concerne cette provocation
on devrait s'interroger seulement je
suis convaincu que la première liberté
c'est la liberté de l'autre
vous voyez cette salle et à mesure de la
libérer la libye